president-elect macron has confirmed the
withdrawal of french troops from mali
after 10 years macron denied the french
mission in mali ended in failure but he
accused mali's transitional government
of forcing french troops to pull out
france and european allies will continue
what they call a joint action against
terrorism in the sahara region
we cannot stay engaged militarily next
to authorities who do not share our
strategy nor our objectives that's the
situation we are confronted by in mali
today
in these conditions france and its
partners in this fight against terrorism
and the states participating in the
takuba task force have taken the
decision to remove military forces from
mali this removal will begin by the
closure of bases in gosi menaka and gao
it will be ordered with the malian
military forces and the u.n forces in
mali
during this period we will maintain our
mission in support for the un
peacekeeping mission as well
for us at monetary events from senegal's
capital of dhaka and nasa to tell us
more about this announcement and its
implications
yeah we thought that this would happen
the relations with mali have really
suffered uh since the military coup just
lost at the end of last month the french
ambassador was given 72 hours to leave
the country that's after the french
foreign minister had called the military
junta in mali illegitimate now there is
increasing anti-french sentiment in the
region especially in mali there were
celebrations on the street when the
ambassador was told to leave so the
situation for france has changed now
what emmanuel macron has just said that
they will be uh having a coordinated uh
withdrawal from the north first and this
could take four to six months but now he
also said that the center for this fight
against terrorism as they call it will
now be niger now france does have
a
presence in west africa in some of the
neighboring countries but also emmanuel
macron is has acknowledged that there is
a change here in west africa there have
been several cues that have taken place
uh and there is an increase in
anti-french sentiment so it's not as
easy as just taking troops from one
country and putting it putting them in
another france would really have to
consider what impact uh that will have
on the political politics in the region
all right i said thanks very much indeed
for that that's a big reporting there
thanks a lot